die fdp könnte zum königsmacher werden
in dieser wahl das wird besonders
spannend auch mit blick auf die
koalition in philipp da viele aber jetzt
eine wortwahl und wir sprechen wieder
von den öffentlichen-rechtlichen die ist
hier ganz besonders ins auge gefallen
ganz genau ich habe gestern wie jeden
abend die tagesschau geschaut toller
nachrichtenüberblick aber dann bin ich
an einer stelle doch hängen geblieben
und zwar als eingespielt wurde wie armin
laschet vor einem rot-rot-grünen bündnis
warnt also einem bündnis aus spd grünen
und der linkspartei und der
nachrichtensprecher einfach sagte er
warnt vor einem
mitte-links-bündnis aber ist an diesem
bündnis mitte sein soll verstehe ich nun
mal gar nicht letztens einen beitrag
wird reinschauen führt
am morgen stellt armin laschet 100 tage
programm vor viel neues steckt da nicht
drin der kandidat warnt erneut vor einem
mitte links bündnis es wird eine
richtungsentscheidung werden und beide
frau baerbock und herr scholz haben auch
deutlich gemacht dass sie ein rot rot
grünes bündnis für möglich halten also
rot rot grün ist dort
mitte-links-bündnis klamm ist uns das
noch einmal auseinander richtig ein
mitte links bündnis heißt für mich dass
eine partei der mitte mit einer linken
partei koaliert ich sehe in der spd und
in den grünen zwei linke parteien links
ist überhaupt kein problem aber die
linkspartei ist nun mal nicht einfach
links die ist linksextrem und wenn armin
laschet verwarnt und muss ja nicht alles
teilen aber hier hatte ein punkt und ich
glaube ganz viele menschen in
deutschland haben eine große sorge vor
der linkspartei weil das seine partei
ist völlig ungeklärtes verhältnis zur
ddr hat beziehungsweise ein falsch rum
geklärtes der hat wirklich fast gar
keine probleme mit der sozialistischen
diktatur
deswegen spricht sie auch davon dass sie
selbst sozialismus in deutschland
informieren würde sie hat kein problem
mit den ganzen diktaturen die es auf
unserer welt gibt von von china über
russland diese partei könnte
außenpolitisch mit der afg problemlos
skalieren haben wir gestern beim
vierkampf auch gesehen beide finden die
nato durch beide wollen mit putin
kuscheln und diese partei die
deutschland wirklich aus den angeln
heben will in ein mitte-links-bündnis
einzuordnen wenn ich einfach fatal und
die kritik richtet sich auch nicht die
tagesschau sondern auch an die grünen
die spd den bündnis mit dieser
linkspartei einfach nicht ausschließen
wollen das sind die parteien jedoch
ständig darüber sprechen dass es
brandmauern nach rechts gibt zurecht
aber wo bleibt die brandmauer nach links
aber wenn du die grünen für eine linke
partei hält trotz seines robert habeck
trotz eines winfried kretschmann in
baden württemberg und obwohl viele
wähler ja eine bürgerliche mitte partei
eigentlich daran wenn du sie für eine
linke partei dann wäre ja ein jamaika
bündnis aus union fdp mit den grünen ein
mitte-links-bündnis völlig richtig so
könnte man es sehen ich sehe die grünen
ehrlich gesagt nicht trotz eines robert
habeck als linke partei ist und ich
würde eher sagen wegen eines robert
habeck auch wenn man robert habeck
zuhört und er ist ein fantastischer
redner dann spricht er von gigantischen
umverteilungs und
transformationsprozessen und diese
vorstellung dass die politik anfängt
wirtschaft und gesellschaft
umzugestalten man mag das gut oder
schlecht finden aber überhaupt dieser
umgestaltung des umverteilungs gedanke
selbst ist für mich etwas zutiefst
linkes winfried kretschmann nämlich da
außen vor er war tatsächlich immer so
der schwarze onkel der der grünen der im
uhr konservativen baden württemberg ist
geschafft hat cdu und grün und grüne in
sich selbst und seiner person zu
vereinen die bundes partei geht immer
weiter nach links
[Musik]